welcome to this video playing DWG 6 from
the UK sorry then that's a freedom
master 2 215 rated yeah you can also
sacrifice the porn but I don't want to
get into any complicated line because I
don't just don't really know what what
is going on ok hmm interesting
hmm Bishop to d6
this listen is there some way maybe 92
92 night XD to Bishop d6 Knight f3 check
GF bc
hmm it looks interesting
Bishop f4 94 just winced upon so he
needs to take on the two
check
I didn't didn't take that into account
yeah I don't think it's particularly
great but I didn't see it okay d takes
or Queen takes Queen takes and yeah he's
got a quick b6 coming yeah this is a bit
more bit more aggressive Quincy three
attacking g7 yeah this looks like a good
position for white queen e five i have a
form i just have to better pc on f1
compared to c 8 and I've got Luke g1 the
double porn is some quite serious and
asset here
for and Bishop g2 this Muslim the idea
trying to keep his bishop out of play
yeah it probably needs to do something
like that some radical measure um yeah
do I take come on let's see nuts and I
thought he needs to take on c3 really
this is a very one-sided position so
Bishop d7 does Queen c7 and what I need
to prevent Bishop Knight what green
before check so I'd he ignored all of
that strangely enough or thought now
Bishop b5 and it's it's gone isn't it I
needed to prevent this check here so
look t7 their smoke checks
hmm
look teasing Luke season is not working
queen bee sevens rugby idea
don't tell me this is not working at all
Luke v8
maybe
so rock d7 look piece of candy to do
this son and this wasn't planned now
it's probably not bad even but i didn't
i didn't want to do that i had some some
other idea okay just take it it's not so
clear okay play for Bishop be six and A
five
well now be should be six it's a it's
quite substantial yeah I thought Jesus
wasn't wasn't working at all but maybe
I'm mistake and I overlooked already
some things in this game I don't have
much time so I need to be quick about it
but his seven checkers is really a big
big threat
yeah all this was completely unnecessary
probably but yeah like I forgot about
about this rook b8 possibility
check
King here is got to Queen a three so I
must go here
you seven shake
all rights it's it's a mate Queenie this
is homemade fortunately check check your
mating first check checkmate whoo ah
this was a Mossad I just thought okay
let's play a three and he cannot go
Bishop d7 because of this and this and
it's not clear or I just didn't realize
rook c8 queen bee seven root beer don't
hear this must be must be very good for
what then of course a three is also not
the best just just this one probably he
just has some developing problems this
is just more active time something like
this it's already very tricky ah and
let's check the Queen sac that was just
yeah not planned beforehand it's
probably the computer says it's a draw
with King King 2 h8 now and this is
probably good for wide right I five it's
computer place Quincy fight with the
draw hmm withdraw how exactly is it a
draw I know it says widest better
interest check I had this idea that now
I can take on g6 and it is working I
couldn't calculate this I did it is
indeed winning Wow
you can give a couple of checks but it
doesn't seem to help yeah I didn't see
it really I was just hoping that
something like that would would work
yank them and he M get the computer it
plays moves like this and this is strong
yeah and if you veneers if you see the
move played out by the comp you
understand why it is good because it
prevents rook takes be too but this is
incredibly difficult to play it gives so
this is about equal yeah but it was an
interesting game I hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching